Варіаційний квантовий власний розв'язувач, або VQE, — це один із перших гібридних квантово-класичних алгоритмів, і він
цікавий з кількох причин. По-перше, як ми побачимо у цьому відео, це перспективний підхід для певних типів задач. По-друге, він важливий
з історичної точки зору і проклав шлях для багатьох вдосконалених алгоритмів, як-от adapt VQE.
І нарешті, VQE досить простий. Легко зрозуміти, що роблять квантовий і класичний комп'ютери в цьому алгоритмі
і як вони взаємодіють. У розрахунку VQE є чотири основні компоненти.
По-перше, є оператор, часто гамільтоніан, який ми назвемо H, що описує властивість системи,
яку ти хочеш оптимізувати. Інакше кажучи, ти шукаєш власний вектор цього оператора, що
відповідає мінімальному власному значенню. Цей власний вектор ми часто називаємо основним станом.
Далі є анзац — слово, що означає «підхід». Це quantum circuit, який готує квантовий стан, що наближає
власний вектор, який ти шукаєш. По суті, анзац — це сімейство quantum circuits, адже деякі gates у
анзаці є параметризованими. Тобто вони отримують параметр, який ми можемо змінювати. Це сімейство quantum circuits
може підготувати сімейство квантових станів, що наближають основний стан.
Далі нам потрібен естиматор — засіб оцінювання очікуваного значення оператора H для поточного варіаційного
квантового стану. Іноді нас цікавить саме це очікуване значення, яке ми
називаємо функцією вартості. Інколи нас цікавить складніша функція, яку все одно можна записати, починаючи з
одного або кількох очікуваних значень.
І нарешті, нам потрібен класичний оптимізатор — алгоритм, що змінює параметри, щоб мінімізувати цю функцію вартості.
Давай окреслимо задачу, яку ми хочемо вирішити, і загальний підхід, перш ніж розглянути роль квантових обчислень. Ми
можемо звести багато задач оптимізації, важливих для науки та промисловості, до матричних задач на власні значення. Зазвичай тобі
потрібне мінімальне власне значення матриці та відповідний власний вектор. Матриця H може бути
гамільтоніаном, що описує енергію фізичної системи. А мінімальне власне значення — це енергія основного стану
E0, а власний вектор — відповідний квантовий основний стан, який часто позначають SI sub0.
Або матриця може описувати складну функцію вартості, пов'язану із задачами комбінаторної оптимізації,
наприклад у логістиці, а власний стан s subopt буде оптимальним розв'язком
задачі — наприклад, бінарним рядком, що позначає розріз у графі розподільної мережі. На практиці
термін «гамільтоніан» часто використовують для всіх матриць, що нас цікавлять, навіть за межами фізичних наук. Припустимо,
нас цікавить матриця з n рядками і n стовпцями. Такі задачі можна вирішувати швидко й точно за допомогою
класичних розв'язувачів для n до кількох сотень або тисяч без жодних припущень про матрицю. Для розріджених
матриць, тобто тих, де більшість елементів — нулі, n може бути значно більшим — до мільярда навіть на ноутбуці.
Але для справді величезних задач, що виходять за ці межі, часто потрібні наближені або евристичні методи.
Чим більша матриця і чим менш розріджена, тим складніша задача і тим хитріші прийоми доводиться застосовувати. Припустимо, твоя матриця така
велика, що точна діагоналізація неможлива. Припустимо також, що ти достатньо знаєш свою задачу, щоб
зробити деякі здогадки про загальну структуру цільового стану, і хочеш досліджувати стани, подібні до твого
початкового здогаду, щоб перевірити, чи можна ще знизити вартість або енергію. Це варіаційний підхід, і це один із методів,
який застосовують, коли точна діагоналізація на класичному комп'ютері неможлива. Це працює так.
По-перше, ти робиш пробний стан із деякими параметрами theta, які будеш змінювати.
Хоча цей початковий здогад може бути випадковим, це небажано. Ми хочемо використати знання про задачу,
щоб максимально налаштувати наш здогад.
По-друге, ми обчислюємо очікуване значення оператора при цьому стані системи.
По-третє, ми змінюємо варіаційні параметри і повторюємо.
По-четверте, ми використовуємо накопичену інформацію про ландшафт можливих станів у твоєму варіаційному підпросторі, щоб робити дедалі кращі
здогади і наближатися до цільового стану.
Варіаційний принцип гарантує, що наш варіаційний стан не може дати власне значення, нижче ніж у
цільового основного стану. Тому чим нижче очікуване значення, тим краще наше наближення до основного стану. Поговорімо
про складність кожного кроку в цьому підході.
Встановлення або оновлення параметрів — обчислювально легке завдання. Складність тут — у виборі корисних фізично
мотивованих початкових параметрів. Використання накопиченої інформації з попередніх ітерацій для оновлення параметрів так,
щоб наближатися до основного стану, — нетривіальне завдання. Але існують класичні алгоритми оптимізації, які роблять
це досить ефективно. Ця класична оптимізація є дорогою лише тому, що може вимагати багатьох
ітерацій. У найгіршому випадку кількість ітерацій може зростати експоненційно з n.
Найдорожчий обчислювально одиничний крок — майже напевно обчислення очікуваного значення твоєї матриці для
заданого стану. Матриця n на n має діяти на вектор із n елементів, що відповідає порядку n у квадраті
операцій множення в найгіршому випадку. Це потрібно робити на кожній ітерації параметрів. Для надзвичайно
великих матриць це має високу обчислювальну вартість. Тепер уяви, що цю частину
розрахунку виконує квантовий комп'ютер. Замість обчислення цього очікуваного значення ти оцінюєш його, готуючи
стан s від theta на квантовому комп'ютері за допомогою свого варіаційного анзацу і потім роблячи вимірювання.
Розгляньмо це детальніше. H загалом нелегко виміряти. Наприклад, він може складатися з багатьох
некомутуючих операторів Паулі x, y і z.
Але H можна записати як лінійну комбінацію членів H subalpha, кожен із яких легко виміряти. Наприклад,
оператори Паулі або групи побітово комутуючих операторів Паулі.
Очікуване значення H для стану S — це зважена сума очікуваних значень складових членів H alpha.
Цей вираз справедливий для будь-якого стану s, але ми будемо використовувати його саме з нашим варіаційним станом s від theta.
Кожен із членів h alpha можна виміряти m разів, отримуючи вибірки вимірювань s subalpha j, де j пробігає від
1 до m, і він повертає очікуване значення та стандартне відхилення. Ми можемо підсумувати
ці члени і провести накопичення похибок через суму.
Це не вимагає великомасштабного множення і жодного процесу, що обов'язково масштабується як n у квадраті. Натомість
це вимагає кількох вимірювань на квантовому комп'ютері. Якщо їх не надто багато, цей підхід може бути
ефективним. І це квантова частина VQE. Але поговорімо про причини, чому це може бути неефективним. Одна причина
для великої кількості вимірювань — зменшення статистичної невизначеності в оцінках для дуже високої точності
обчислень. Інша причина — кількість рядків Паулі, необхідних для охоплення всієї матриці. Оскільки матриці Паулі плюс
тотожність охоплюють простір усіх операторів заданого виміру, ми гарантовано
можемо записати нашу матрицю інтересу як зважену суму операторів Паулі, як ми робили раніше. Тут C alpha —
числовий коефіцієнт, а H alpha — рядок операторів Паулі, що діють на всі cubits, які описують твою систему.
H alpha матиме такий вигляд, де n-й оператор Паулі справа діє на n-й cubit. Тож ми можемо
виміряти наш оператор, вимірюючи серію операторів Паулі. Але ми не можемо виміряти всі ці оператори Паулі
одночасно. Оператори Паулі, за винятком тотожності, не комутують один з одним, якщо вони
пов'язані з тим самим cubit. Наприклад, ми можемо виміряти I Z IIZ і ZZ
XZ одночасно, тому що для третього cubit ми можемо вимірювати I і Z одночасно.
І для першого cubit ми можемо знати I і X одночасно. Але ми не можемо
виміряти всі Z і ZZ ZX одночасно, тому що Z і X не
комутують і обидва діють на нульовий cubit.
Тож ми розкладаємо нашу матрицю H у суму Паулі, що діють на різні cubits.
Деякі члени цієї суми можна виміряти всі одразу. Ми називаємо це групою комутуючих Паулі. Залежно від
кількості некомутуючих членів нам може знадобитися багато таких груп. Назвемо кількість таких груп комутуючих
Паулі ngcp.
Якщо ngcp мале, це може добре працювати.
Якщо h має мільйони груп, це не буде корисним. Ти записуєш очікуване значення або функцію вартості
для набору параметрів theta, використаних у твоєму стані, а потім оновлюєш параметри з часом. Ти можеш використовувати
оцінені очікувані значення або значення функції вартості, щоб наблизити градієнт своєї функції вартості у
підпросторі станів, вибраних твоїм анзацем.
Існують як градієнтні, так і безградієнтні класичні оптимізатори. Обидва страждають від потенційних проблем з навчанністю, як-от
множинні локальні мінімуми і великі області параметричного простору з майже нульовим градієнтом, що називаються barren plateaus.
То чи вирішить VQE всі твої найскладніші задачі? Ні. Але бути кращим в усіх обчисленнях ніколи і не було метою. Ми
змістили те, що визначає обчислювальну вартість. Подивись, що ми обміняли. Ми перейшли від процесу,
складність якого залежить лише від розміру матриці, до такого, що залежить від необхідної точності і кількості
некомутуючих операторів Паулі, що складають матрицю. Останнє не має аналога в класичних обчисленнях.
З огляду на ці нові залежності для розріджених матриць або матриць із невеликою кількістю некомутуючих рядків Паулі цей
процес може бути корисним. Це стосується систем взаємодіючих спінів. Наприклад, для щільних матриць це може бути
менш корисним. Ми знаємо, наприклад, що хімічні системи часто мають гамільтоніани, що містять сотні, тисячі і навіть
мільйони рядків Паулі. Було проведено цікаву роботу зі зменшення цієї кількості членів, але
хімічні системи можуть краще підходити для деяких інших алгоритмів, які ми розглянемо в цьому курсі.
Ефективне використання VQE також вимагає, щоб ми знали атрибути нашого цільового стану і могли вибрати хороший фізично
мотивований початковий стан, а також хороший анзац із відносно невеликою кількістю варіаційних параметрів. Це може бути
досить складно. VQE демонструє, як можна поєднати сильні сторони класичних і квантових комп'ютерів
без додавання новіших методів. VQE не допомагає нам вирішувати задачі, нерозв'язні для класичних комп'ютерів, але
продовжує відігравати роль у розробці алгоритмів. І VQE також учить нас, що перенесення кроку з класичних
на квантові комп'ютери не є ні кращим, ні гіршим для всіх цілей. Натомість це
змінює те, які фактори визначають ефективність твого алгоритму. Це важливий загальний урок у квантово-
класичних гібридних обчисленнях.